joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
from the home of the NFL Network Reggie
Bush how are you Reggie good I'm doing
fine
what was it what's your first memory of
meeting drew brees Reggie my first
memory of Luton drew was actually I
didn't meet him it was a phone call and
it was the night before his death cinema
hotel room we just found out that Mario
Williams was going to be the first pitch
taken overall we had been told by
casually and by the rest of the Houston
Texans that I was the sure unticked so
when we found out that Houston would be
taking Marlon not before me and might
not minimize my agents and I knew that
the same set of second took and the Jets
had a third pick we wanted to go to New
York so we even had a conversation with
coach Sean Payton where my agent said to
take the time out reading to cook and be
and also because there was a lot of
uncertainty after Katrina you know the
team obviously wasn't hadn't been that
good in a long time so I did a call from
cocaine and basically turns on me you
know yes we're taking friends you no
matter which no matter what you guys won
with unity and then call me do call me
and he says he had a chance to play with
LaDainian Tomlinson who he considered to
be one of the best running backs who's
ever played with and he said that he was
very excited to get a chance to play
with me and was looking forward to it
and he thought that I had a chance to be
as good or better and that moment right
there completely changed my mindset
about going to New Orleans and just put
me in a place of they put me at ease all
the emotions everything I was going on
through my head and really changed my
whole perspective about just you know
going to play in New Orleans and that
was one of my first fondest memories of
q Brees just the kind of person that is
well I think things worked out
you led a team in receptions your rookie
year and I've never known that that you
were trying to orchestrate a way out of
New Orleans and Sean Payton telling its
good buddy Mike gornstein go screw
yourself we're taking your guy and then
drew Brees calls you up put your mind at
ease what was it like though getting
there in New Orleans you point out I
mean this is post-katrina city's trying
to put everything back together
Brees coming back from a shoulder injury
Payton getting his first shot at being
an HD in the NFL Reggie what was that
like yeah you know what it's funny
because when I look back on it now
everything happened for a reason that
team was put together by a higher power
you know obviously the coaches and a
team made the Jetix but I think that
happened at such constant time and
moment for the city of New Orleans
everything that had been you I just
believe it was fate that we came there
together when you look at like he's
imagined you do nobody wanted him after
his shoulder injury everybody thought
his career was done but he was finished
and it happened on a play where he was
you know where he was I believe was
chasing down an interception right so
it's memory serves me correct or
something like that
something in a moment will you know he
was given his a wall and he and then
fast forward when you decide to go right
and nothing what changes everything then
I come and then so on and so forth you
know that draft class was me and Marcus
Colston Roman Harper I'm forgetting some
other names but we're on a plan yeah you
know for a long time and kudos to the
coaches I'm doing a great job
you know seeing as the right talent to
put together the right people and then
we built that chemistry over and of
course those those five years and ended
up winning Super Bowl there but I
believe that team was meant to be that
the city needed seemed like that needed
us and we needed them Reggie
here on the Rich Eisen show so what
makes breeze so great Reggie
give me a good and a good example of his
greatness well we know how he is on a
football field
everything you know I'm a comic over his
career is you know perfect example just
the type of person he is it's not just
he shows up on game days and you know
and and goes out and puts up these huge
numbers but he's just a great person on
and off the football field he's a great
leader he's a great family man
you know he's believing in God and puts
God first and and he's just to all
connect he's the ultimate professional
athlete on and off the football field
and a perfect example that is on my
route here and this was always what I'll
always try to do whatever I was playing
for I would always try to find the
hardest worker on the team and I would
try to outwork him and so when I got to
New Orleans I knew that your greens was
that guy I knew he was the hardest
worker in the room first person on the
field last one off and so I purposely
made it you know my goal to try to
outwork do Brees and I would try to show
up early in the morning before any of
the coaches were there before anybody
would be there to start watching the
film and getting ready for the day for a
week of practice and drew would already
been you know in the film room and I'd
be walking in and his car was already
parked out there and he's already in the
film luminances it's night time I
thought coaches on even idiot and as I'm
leaving you know trying to be one of the
last guy you know officer your watches
over you on the field throwing more
routes you know what 20 30 minutes after
crisis over and so that hard work of
preparation you know is to me is is one
of the reasons why he's such a great
person is his character
Reggie Bush Iran the Rich Eisen show and
then the Saints I mean there
is it a fair way I asked him this the
other day and I knew breeze wasn't gonna
give me a straight answer I asked anyway
yeah and so you you can say I'll ask you
are his current weapons better maybe
than the ones that he had it his
disposal when you first first got there
that's such a great question man because
Michael Thomas is the new Marcus Colston
right you know Ingram and Kamara or with
me and Pierre Thomas were you know at
that time and you know I loved watching
you guys playing a game I love what
they're able to do on the football field
week in a week out I mean they're just
they're so consistent they're tough to
deal with and you know they're finding
different ways to preserve through this
horrible weapon are they better man much
of their DNA what they have now is very
very similar to what we had and and even
on a different side of the ball as well
you know the last night they reminded me
about 2005 football team is everything
about it the way they were getting
pressure recorded that turnovers
you know the run game was there that the
receivers were you know flying past
people down the football field
drew stolen seen routes all over the
place really those couple years those
five years on with how we played I know
you got only about 90 seconds so you
gotta walk into your NFL Total Access
meeting and I don't want you to be late
so I will ask you this Reggie no it's
Sean Payton as well as you do and
knowing he the way that he calls
offenses i as an Alvin camara fantasy
player I am I'm scared I'm scared I'm
nervous I'm panicking I'm in a full-on
panic what can you tell me is this an
appropriate feeling right now about
coming that he's thinking at nine
touches what you know Ingraham comes
back in chimera the chimera I've come to
know and adore and count on the last
four weeks and fantasies behind it help
me out here well you have to know this
about Sean okay
he loves running back by committee he's
not going to put all the eggs in one
basket one of runs back because you know
running backs get banged up and he knew
that in order for him to move on with
the next mogul
he has to keep everybody healthy and
fresh so with that you know England
coming back command centers are gonna go
down a little bit but also last night
was just everything was working for him
right it's not always gonna be like that
you know not every game we're gonna be
having nice grouping you know running
out a football field you know they're
gonna have to rely on the game so how
much have it definitely pump the brakes
and be patient because one of the things
that I do know about Sean is that he's
trying to find one of them running a
football in getting the block his
running back in Spain all right Reggie
thanks man
say hi to everybody have a good meeting
will see on total assists tonight at
7:00
thank you you gotta it's Reggie Bush the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience